do you remember when out last two got
banned in australia it was like just
last week but now everything's changed
i'm tony and this gamespot news update
is banned free out last two will be
released in australia after all the
ratings board has decided to bestow the
game with an r18 plus rating with
warnings of quote high impact horror
themes violence blood gore and sex
what's interesting is that out last two
was not changed in any way when it was
resubmitted to the board so whatever
content they objected to is still very
much in the game that being said I'm all
for adults being able to buy whatever
games they want so I'm happy my
Australian friends don't have to miss
out and be sure to subscribe to gamespot
for any further updates on this whole
situation out last two releases for ps4
xbox one and pc on april 25th in the US
april 26th in australia then you can get
your fill of all that horror and
violence and speaking of violence why
not check out our newest Mass Effect
Andromeda video about all our favorite
guns
[Music]